in front of Argentina's Congress actors
musicians filmmakers and intellectuals
marked the first month in office of
President kavier
M by demanding that lawmakers reject the
executives initiative to cut government
support for cultural
institutions we're demonstrating so that
they don't take our livelihood away from
us we are part of the working class not
a privileged
cast States support for film and arts
has won this country Global
recognition Argentina's Rich cultural
life is one of this country's
outstanding characteristics even through
difficult times it's managed to shine
but should Congress approve the
president and precedented belt
tightening measures many here say they
will have a very very hard time
surviving Hima sales is a film editor
who depends at least in part on highly
competitive grants from the National
Institute for Cinema and visual arts she
argues that cutting its funding will not
only hurt filmmakers but Argentina's
cultural
sovereignty culture is important for
everyone not just the workers it
reinforces our national
identity but Argentina's economy is in
crisis deep in debt and with triple
digit inflation the only solution says
the president is for con con to approve
an emergency Bill to slash social
spending and privatize everything
possible outside Congress these
protesters respond with calls for a
national
strike this as Argentina's largest Trade
union Confederation calls for a
Countrywide action later this month a
crucial litmus test for the new
president's plans to dismantle Latin
America's oldest welfare state
Lu Al jazer buenos
Idis make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer